I came home from vacation
recently, jet-lagged, tired,
after delayed flights and a lost bag,
with my cranky preschooler
and my husband trudging behind me,
and I forgot the code to my front door.
We've lived in this house for seven years.
I'd put the code in the door
hundreds of times before.
And as I stood there,
staring at the keypad, I thought,
"Oh boy, I'm finally losing my mind."
Our brains have an incredible
capacity to store memory,
but not all of that information
is accessible at once.
An article in
“Scientific America[n]” estimates
the human brain can store 2.5
million gigabytes of data.
That's about 5,000 iPhones.
But if you've ever forgotten
a password before,
you know that memory
is not always easy to access
because memory is not just one system.
Those different systems have limits,
and a number of factors in our daily lives
can impact our memory efficiency.
There was a famous
neuropsychology case study
of a patient referred to as patient HM,
who became like a real-life Ten-Second Tom
after brain surgery
to treat a seizure disorder.
In terms of his seizures,
the surgery was a success.
They were less severe and less frequent.
But after his surgery,
HM became unable to consciously
learn new things.
For example, he worked with the same
neuropsychologist for years.
He never remembered meeting her,
he’d introduce himself each time.
And he never remember
doing the different tasks
that she would bring to test his memory.
But here's the interesting part.
His performance got better
on some of those tasks over time.
He never remember doing them.
He always thought he was doing
them for the first time.
But his brain had learned the procedures
without him being aware.
We learned from patient HM
and others like him
that there are different types of memory.
Some memories come to mind
almost automatically.
Like if you're walking through a garden
and you smell the flowers
that your grandma
used to keep on her kitchen table,
and all of a sudden, you're thinking
of your favorite memory with your grandma.
But other memories take more brainpower
and effort to recall.
Like trying to remember
my new computer password.
Because some memories take more
brainpower and effort to recall,
they're also more prone to interference.
You're at the grocery store,
and you’re trying to remember
10 things that you need to pick up.
But you run into your neighbor
in the produce section,
and after a few minutes of chit chat,
hearing about their new car,
you can only remember two
of those 10 things.
Even though our memory storage
is pretty impressive --
5,000 iPhones big --
the short-term memory that you're using
to keep track of your grocery list
is more like seven, plus or minus
two, bits of information.
And it's really easy to throw that active
short-term memory off track.
The problem?
We live in a very
distracting modern world.
You're at a meeting at work,
and you're trying to remember
all the details of a project
that you're working on
so that you can share it with your team.
But at the same time,
your brain is paying attention
to what your colleagues are saying,
trying to ignore all the email alerts
popping up on your computer,
distracted by text messages
from your family
asking what's for dinner,
and wondering if they're going
to take a break soon
because you could really
use some more coffee.
Ignoring all those distractions
and competing priorities
takes up a lot of energy.
When our brains are juggling 400 things,
we're more likely to make a memory error,
like forgetting a colleague’s
name in a meeting
or missing a key part
of your presentation,
and then beating yourself up
for the rest of the day
for making that mistake.
Which brings us to another
brain-draining habit
that can mess up your memory
and make it hard to remember
where you left your keys:
stress.
Doesn't have to be huge
or major stressors, either.
All those day-to-day stresses, pressures
and deadlines take up brain space, too,
and force our brain to do
a bunch of mental multitasking.
Last summer, I locked myself
in a stairwell twice in the same week
because I was trying to do
this mental multitasking.
I was packing up at the end of the day,
and at the same time,
I was thinking about phone calls
I needed to make tomorrow,
and ideas for a project
that I was working on
and what I was going to make
for supper that night
and whether I should pick up my daughter
before or after I get groceries.
And I left my keys in my office.
Twice in the same week.
Apparently, door locks aren't my thing.
An article from Queen's University
estimates we have 6,200 thoughts each day.
That's a lot of potential
for distractions.
There was a study
at the University of California
that found when we're interrupted,
like with distractions or multitasking,
we try to compensate by working faster.
But this makes us feel more stressed.
And as you can imagine,
it's not very efficient.
We've all been in situations
where we feel a bit stressed out
and overwhelmed by our
never-ending to do lists.
Between emails and phone calls
and Zoom meetings and project deadlines,
we’re coming home from work feeling tired,
and our brains are burnt out.
There was an article published
in the journal “Science of Learning”
that showed stress not only impacts
our memory retrieval,
so it's hard to remember
that door code when you need it,
stress also makes it hard
for our brains to problem-solve
and think of creative solutions,
like how I'm going to get into my house
when I can't remember my door code.
We know all those day-to-day
stresses, pressures
and deadlines can mess up our memory.
But what about bigger stresses,
like the uncertainty and change
of living through a multi-year pandemic,
financial pressure, family stress?
These stresses drain brain resources, too,
making us more likely to make mistakes
and making it harder to remember
the things we need to remember.
So memory errors are normal,
especially when you’re tired, overworked
or stressed out.
That's great to know,
but I still need to get into my house
at the end of my vacation.
How do we boost our memory
in these situations
and recharge those brain cells?
It's tempting to try
and just think harder,
but that doesn't always work.
Have you ever been trying to think
of the name of a movie or an actor,
and it's right on the tip of your tongue,
but you can't quite remember it?
And then four hours later,
you're driving home from work
and that name comes to you
out of the blue?
Yeah, me too.
Totally normal.
When it comes to our memory,
thinking harder doesn't always work.
Because of a process
of competitive inhibition
of the neurons in your brain.
Basically, when you try to think too hard
about one super specific piece of memory,
like a name or a code,
the brain cells in that part of your brain
get overloaded and blocked.
They need time to recharge.
That’s why, four hours later,
that memory comes back to you.
It's still there,
still in your memory storage,
just the access route has been exhausted
and needs time to reset.
Plus, remember how stress makes
our brains less efficient?
When we're worried about making mistakes,
we're more likely to make more mistakes.
Do this instead:
if you’re feeling
more forgetful than usual,
or your brain feels stuck
and you can't seem to find
the memory you need,
it might be a sign
that your brain needs a reset.
Can’t remember a code or a password,
standing at your door like me,
and you can think of every
four-digit code you know,
except the one you need?
Think about something else
for a few minutes.
Anything else.
Chat with the store clerk at the grocery
store about the weather
instead of staring at the debit machine,
trying to remember your bank code,
or pull out your phone and scroll
social media for a few minutes.
This works because instead
of exhausting the brain cells
you need to find that memory,
you activate other parts of your brain,
giving those memory centers
a chance to recharge and reset.
Making more mistakes than normal at work,
you can’t seem to send
an email without a typo
or you’re stumbling
over your words in a meeting ...
get up and take a real break.
Go for a walk around your office
or do something fun for a few minutes.
These micro breaks
refresh your mental resources
and give your brain back
the energy and focus it needs
to find that information.
Memory errors aren't a sign
you're losing your mind.
They might be a sign your brain
needs a little break and a reset.
Thank you.